so my dad my dad's the coolest person I  know my dad doesn't drink he doesn't  smoke he doesn't have social media when  I quit my job and told him that I wanted  to be a YouTuber  he was a bit shocked um he but the one  thing I love about my dad is my dad is  so supportive and ever since I was a kid  he always told me to follow what you're  passionate about and he would tell me I  don't care if you make money selling  toothpicks on the side of the road do  what you love because you are going to  work harder at it than everybody else  and that's like the general strategy  I've always had he always still need to  chase skills not money and do what you  like because you're going to put in more  hours than everyone else he also said it  can't be about the money because you're  going to get burnt out and it has to be  something that you genuinely enjoy doing  because you're going to be doing it for  a very long time